hello happy Thursday it's Thursday
that's Erin I'm Eric today we're gonna
be checking out Ghost Recon wildlands
but the ghost door beta which is a PvP
mode Erin's actually in a game so I'm
just gonna hop over here real quick
you have been marked but here you are
you're using your drone it's essentially
team guy king corrupt
77 working on our bullet drops they
paint here so yeah Ghost Recon wildlands
like finally has PvP it's four before
for view for team deathmatch
come revive me bros it is not a not
really objective base right now there's
a radio tower in the middle of the map
that people can get to to reveal the
other team and everybody started off as
trainees right now that happened to
roans but when we played in a preview
event before this I believe only the
scout class in this trainee class had
the drones so there's a lot more drones
in the air right now than the last last
time we played this game gotcha yeah and
and just so people know it is a beta so
if you see people kind of dropping in
and out of matches that's probably why
but yeah we're checking it out we're
trying to see if it's worth your time is
it an open beta Aaron is this yeah
anyone can get into oh cool PC and I
think actually Xbox one and ps4 you can
just go ahead and download it it's
actually so it's not in your currently
installed game it's actually a separate
thing that your parents mode that you
have to go get yeah actually
quick from the store yeah so if you just
fire up wildlands today and you don't
see it that's why it's you have to
actually get it separately okay it's
cool though I'd like the slower pace of
things I was a huge fan of Ghost Recon
phantoms and I played some multiplayer
and future soldier there's just so many
like fast paced games out there that I
like the slower pace of these
I I've covered me shooters okay but I
will say it one thing that's a bit of a
disappointment is rather than go like
the GTA route or go the battlefield
route particularly with all of the
vehicles available it's in wildlands and
how extensive wildlands is this feels
like just a very simple proof of concept
it's it's just small arms and soldiers
only it does have its own skill tree and
unlock tree which is pretty cool so you
have you have a reason to go through it
that is not based on the the main game
check but yeah like I don't know it
feels like this is part of the a trend
of who be soft pvp experiments one of
those with siege where they just sort of
start small promise low and see how it
goes and then the community kind of
build it up yes early yeah so just so
you guys know I am in YouTube twitch and
games watch at if you guys have
questions Aaron is my expert today I
will passing those along but glad you
guys are all tuning in if you didn't
know already we go alive every day at 11
a.m.
checking out different new kind of cool
games different betas alphas etc as you
see today we haven't unlocked another
class yet right we're stuck in recruit
mode because we just started yeah we
just started this morning so there's a
basic recruits
he's your average multi class it's funny
because actually again going back to
siege I think really good people later
on just sort of went multi class because
they could pick it every time I just
went with the recruit and also they
seemed to have the drone and they also
have from the bill that we saw the only
other designated marksman rifle in the
game other than the actual dedicated
support sorry marksman sniper class so
we've seen them in the preview field we
saw four classes but each of them have
two subclasses that you unlock okay I
spent a lot of time in the preview event
playing scout because they have the
drone and they can call in an hour
Tillery strike which is kind of a huge
thing Bob Jones wants to know do you
have to reset the story to play the DLC
this DLC is standalone it's okay and
right now it's in beta yeah so if you're
looking to try you know go find the
ghost or beta and you should be able to
download it yeah I don't think you have
to have the base game to play so there's
our team marking their team huh you
can't destroy the drone obviously you
shot went down earlier but just so you
guys know you see an enemy drone you can
shoot it it's a risk though because if
the drone doesn't see you then if you
start shooting at it it's gonna know
exactly where you are you can also like
everybody can use their binoculars if
you can perón your way out of it so
there's also some interesting classes in
this game the enforcer class the support
enforcer class can actually take the
mark off of the entire rest of your team
Wow and put it on themselves and they
have like 115 health O's that they
they'd be ok it's like almost like as
you mentioned like a tank class at once
yeah so they can unmark and then help
your team out
there's definitely gimmick cat-and-mouse
here they just spotted me so they have a
general idea of where I'm at I think a
lot of this also comes down to sound and
just figuring out where people are so
you just heard the recon tower come up
in the middle mm-hmm that is where
everybody goes to dude right here I
don't think I'm really getting with a
grenade now down there are revived hit
the wrong button sorry not my
okay but you said that you can revive
your fallen teammates right yeah so he's
actually probably in a pretty good
revival spot the one problem actually in
I asked Thames if they included it but
there's no smoke in this game okay
not yet not yeah yeah again this is a
beta I'm sure a lot of testing no but
you just God so I just melee do you mail
a there was no one on top of me I don't
know it says you got nice yep there he
is get them get them thank you guys yeah
there's two of them right there I tossed
a need in that direction I was kind of
hoping we still there oh yeah oh oh no
all right again just so you guys know
beta we'll see how it shakes out here oh
no this is this map is a heavy heavy
snapping Maps okay so here's what you
can do when you're you can either just
use this to mark and so I'm right here I
like I know they're here I can tell my
team they're here it's interesting I
actually just discovered around ago when
their drone comes up if you stay on this
map you can see it come up and you can
mark where their drone first appeared
which is probably where the soldier is
that a key is not easy to control
especially big or just kind of
mentioning that to is that the guns have
an extreme amount of recoil it's a very
kind of feels a lot slower which again I
like like I think it's a different style
right there's a lot of those faster
paced shooters out there so okay so we
just hit level three we have one skill
point we can put it into something
hopefully I can now buy my favorite
scout that has a stret like a artillery
strike okay that sounds cool we'll see
what happens alright we're setting up
for our next match here in the ghost war
beta for Ghost Recon wildlands the PvP
mode is out today open beta according to
like I hear Aaron so if you're
interested in playing that you could go
find it it's not part of Ghost Recon
wildlands itself right you said it's
like kind of like a standalone thing
that you have to download separately so
if you're trying to download it find it
separately obviously we are currently
playing on ps4 for those curious but
it's also housed on PC right yeah I
think it's also again in Ghost Recon
fashion in here it's bro the matter we
got to do it every time huh that's kind
of a little yeah so we've been having to
mute players obviously now in most cases
you fight don't want to go for call-outs
and stuff but you probably dream I will
have him mute them is your character
customization from the base game carried
to the beta or does it just give you a
vanilla player model its standalone but
there is character customization and I
believe that cuz some of that comes to
customization is unlocked okay so you
can look prestigious gameplay yeah gotta
give you a reason to keep my guy what
does it take for me to unlock this just
your teammates okay let me try and turn
down their squad audio I guess turned
down squad volume so yeah as David
mentioned normally you'd not want to do
this is a game where you definitely want
to be communicating it's just when
you're streaming you don't want to hear
it you know what I probably got a point
for my class abilities one of them's
running hey run good we're going a
lumber mill now again goob this is like
a slow it's like a little bit slower you
know yo so the style of multiplayer here
you also have some pretty classic
mechanics the light machine guns do
suppress other players the sniper class
is a subclass of the marksman they are
the only person who can shoot through
cover in this game against some of the
other interesting things the Scout they
have more powerful drones and one of
them has a drone that can drop artillery
strikes and they have land mines too so
it's very class-based
like there's a reason why it's actually
I think for the beta they start
everybody as the recruit the recruit
just maybe to give you something to
grind towards and to test that but in
the build that we saw the dead build
that we thought we had all all of them
all of them locked and it's definitely a
better match when you can mix and match
classes yeah totally so a couple of
questions and comments coming in thanks
cake or in the YouTube chat saying it's
a fun a game type but they definitely
need to try to add like another
ingredient to it to give it a twist kind
of like Rainbow six siege and then Niner
gang 49 asking how do you like it I
can't even get a game to load up people
join and disconnect almost always I will
say Aaron was having some people kind of
go in and out on him earlier but it
seems to be getting better now maybe
more people are getting the mode and
getting into the game so you know you'll
probably have a higher probability of
being able to play full matches but it
is beta obviously so don't be shocked if
there's a you know some some
disconnecting going on that was a good
play by carnage 420 yeah I mean again
this amount of cover with the Grenada
this game is also very sound based when
you start shooting people know you're
there there you go so there are revives
and there's also this thing called
adrenaline rush so there's only one
person left on your team they can't be
suppressed and they can have I think
they might revive slightly faster nice
so are you revival the entire match you
are I've actually it's not like you
bleed out kind of thing yeah I've tried
to execute people when they were already
down it seems like you're in a permanent
revived state okay so not like pub G
which can lead to some pretty tense
situations where there's like two people
left and one of them goes to try to
revive their teammate and who like you
know if somebody does provide multiple
teammates they'll probably win but
somebody can also can't bodies my guys
are so far people well right now
they have a pretty confident squad
different class classes it looks like to
James manager says hey Ganga I love your
channel smiley face hey James thanks for
tuning in thanks for the kind words
thank you
hopefully returning you were but I
appreciate it as always I mean we play
for you guys so what you guys want to
see products 93 saying wine isn't
working I haven't heard too much in
terms of issues but you can always try
you know closing out your game coming
back maybe something like the the kind
of crappy thing maybe to do would have
to be like uninstalled reinstall so at
least you have like a mini game you can
kind of play here to to help your
teammates right it kind of seems like oh
there's a guy right there oh no right I
can mark areas on the map even when I'm
dead
gosh yeah so actually one person and
again like going back to Rainbow six
siege if you're dead you can still be of
use to your team here its cameras there
I just marked him so it's cameras and
see each here you can hop up on this map
and you can actually give your team some
location oh I just got nice he did work
that dismal guy can you kill at least
two or three people I'm not gonna I'm
not good with aks and any shooter and
unfortunately this guy has the AAA as
the starting weapon mr. jazz annex jasm
xx says damn I wanted this in wildlands
for so long well it's finally here give
it a give it a shot yeah and I gotta say
like I talked to the developers and my
impression is they're gonna start small
and see how the community responds to it
they said they're open to ideas they
have definitely idle I mean they said
and I brought it up too because a lot of
people have a lot of people have said to
them hey can we just have battle royale
because this game more than most other
games really feels equip for that
especially with the the vehicles in the
game so they've heard that feedback
where for me I just want to see what
that does it appearance customize so you
can kind of so as somebody had mentioned
earlier there's things you can change
now I don't know if it's porting over
your stuff from wildlands itself maybe
it will in the future but at least you
can kind of customize your character a
bit I do not believe it does yeah I
think it doesn't look like it's so far
right but you never know I did get an
unlock point though and I'm curious I
haven't figured out how to spend it yet
okay seek a shot you says turn your ek
to single fire good point you know left
on the d-pad thanks for the tip there
well you can try that out you gotta aim
down sight to do that in this game I'll
give that a try I think rabbi
McLovin I think you just fire up the
bait on its own right you don't fire up
the base game no you do not think betas
like on its own like almost like game
essentially right if you can't find it
you do not fire up the base game you go
download this separately gotcha so this
is binoculars right so yeah use your
binoculars oh so he's right there
there's no way he's a sniper and I can
see that I can see that you got someone
he got our sniper I got Jew too smooth
man you know what I really want right
now that was a smoke grenade hey you
never know could be coming maybe it's a
class-based thing down the road did you
play every class see do you get points
for Oh Oh interesting so I actually was
forced into G kneeling position when I
tried to revive I got someone else loco
oh wait so we're we're pretty much like
pinned down on this ridge we got to go a
different direction their Scout is
effective I'm actually more worried
about that on PC where people are just
way better at sniping possible it's
always been the huge classic how is the
arty there
because you guys didn't cover your bases
Braden Williams saying I really hope we
get larger maps vehicles and like 50
people slash objective gameplay I mean
if they're starting at this size I don't
see that oh there was a guy right in
front of him I hope he saw just like ran
by him nope he got killed yeah
all right guy at the lumber mill by
himself son head back you know I do
wonder if this game won't have the siege
problem where people who want to play
tactical just get beat by people who are
aggressive I feel like at the end of the
day siege devolved into if you use
gadgets you actually kind of had a
disadvantage because somebody could just
run into a room and spray I somehow find
me the balance right with siege there
was kind of like it was more objective
based right so at least you're defending
a spot or defending an area whereas this
kind of just makes it like okay you got
a guy that's good come back get to come
back if they're smart though they're
also like camping our bodies I know you
explained this surveillance tower but
does that just basically give away the
enemy's position or yeah the entire
other team I think when it comes down to
it because there's no objective outside
of just killing each other like to know
it main objective you the main objective
is just to kill each other
okay so there's never like at like after
five minutes or something like there's
some objective that you then have to
like hold or get or whatever it's just
basically TDM yeah and the point of the
radio tower I think is pacing more than
anything they just don't want people
camping out in the woods yeah I mean
like that's what I mean I I felt like
there would be some type of a tiebreaker
situation where a lot of these games are
having like you know hey there's a thing
you need to defuse or plans to force the
issue of ending around with it looks
more like shooting and we're see behind
us
deathmatch Oh grenades right now desert
is their friendly fire at all right now
grenades our friendly fire okay so you
can't hurt your own teammates I'm gonna
try the single shot advice we'll see how
this goes well it should give you a
little bit more like aim and accuracy
our guys way ahead of us he can I go in
a 1v1 if he isn't careful gonna go cover
him music for all you know the other
teams just hanging out and building and
stuff I don't know like I I am
personally not into this like Today
article multiplayer but see why people
are there's definitely somebody here
with that means actually and I'm messing
with our whole team we're gonna find
that's what I would do I think every
round is just try to like we got to find
the other side and flank you guys was
like an AR or something that's neptr
okay that's pretty sneaky whoever has
the drone right now so he's saucing
grenades he's through like he should be
through most of his grenades now
there he is how's that feel compared to
the kind of bursty fire feels like I'm
worried I won't get enough rounds on
target
bring out call me out cool arrows it's
almost all the situations where I feel
like you want to take custody of their
bodies yeah you want to just camp their
bodies all right to force the other team
to revive okay so we're back online
that's why the revives in this game
actually sort of were you don't know me
says you can enable friendly fire that's
interesting so I guess there's two
different potential game type modes so
what I was actually worried about cuz
you get you get rewards for on our team
splitting up you get rewards for
reviving shooting
where I was where people with kind of
boost by dropping no don't don't run
ahead she's down now we got two men down
where is he
okay you guys got the tower which is
good I think you vibe right now because
they don't just read why you I think
they they came to one guy came to
obviously revive his teammate so quit
complaining I take a second to engage I
think I got to be careful cuz they're
actually right next to me that's weird
because you have the thing up so so the
mini-map would have showed you where
they were there right there should be
right in front of me right now
no I think they booked it see the I saw
I definitely saw it wouldn't come up
over here okay
so you don't I thought you had the tower
though because they you saw those other
two guys yeah but then we lost them they
went off okay don't run ahead by
yourself do that do that guy yeah it's a
separate download as Kate Gore's
mentioned Prince if you're trying to
play this you have to look for Ghost
Recon war or ghost sorry
ghost war beta and that's a standalone
on its own she'll look for that Ghost
war Ghost Recon war nice good job you're
the only one left oh they traded a
little barrel alright I'm gonna try and
get him up because then it's a
two-on-one unless he revives in which
case an hour and they revived so or no
it's to v3
show me that throwing arm okay to be to
have a grenade left hey where's everyone
you got a guy dear right that you could
potentially go right there alright I'm
not gonna back you drive here they're
gonna try to get the the pinch on here
oh oh so the rounds do have a timer a
lot more life that pub do you like
single fire like how you keep telling
your enemies go down go down please rule
apps are in the YouTube chat yes
immediately
just go download the Ghost Recon war
mode separately it's not part of the
base game so if you're looking to play
the open beta go download this kind of
like standalone mode essentially and do
it I do just show go down repeatedly as
you to exactly so much health says uh
for ports so talk yeah I mean to be fair
they're probably Tier one operators
wearing a lot but I wish more shooters
had it he doesn't like the reviving
though I think that you should be able
like maybe rebuy once but or something
like that there should be some type of
type of penalty that round lasted for
quite a bit of time yeah it's a slower
pace uh it's it's up to you with you
guys like that Arnie exactly I am kind
of over the fast pace again like I
really liked Rainbow six siege when it
started and now it's just too fast for
me like I totally respect that other
people love the counter-strike sort of
fast pacing of siege now but I'm looking
to slow down I love games that a little
bit more slow and tactical battlefield
again like battlefields a game that sped
up way too much in my days
duties always been that way I played a
lot of Ghost Recon phantoms back in the
day and really loved it there goes a
disconnect so the other team is at a
disadvantage but I did see people kind
of join mid-match so I think it'll be
fine but yeah I wouldn't mind seeing a
little bit more health in shooters I
feel like even even though I enjoy the
quickness in terms of like quickness in
play in terms of Call of Duty
especially after playing the world war 2
beta I wished it was like another like
another like 1 to 2 more shots because I
just feel like sometimes it's like oh
well I'm dead I never had a real chance
to fight back
you have two people left definitely got
a win area yeah even without just quick
scoping and Call of Duty like the m1
garand was a two-shot kill if you hit
them upper mass I feel like yeah but
there's a lot of quick scoping going on
yeah so kind of cool to see that Ubisoft
has had some success with competitive
shooters and like you know that those
are like longer type of multiplayer
experiences so limited lamp again if
you're trying to play the beta just get
on to the wall depends on what you're
playing on ps4 or PC but you should be
able to get on to said store look for
the Ghost Recon
I think why be calling a ghost war beta
but look for that because it's not part
of just the Ghost Recon wildlands game
so ok swear I have a point to spend
somewhere can I not maybe keg or or I
gotta back out there fellows that kind
of uh it was gonna put me in a match by
myself Oh gotcha um so the developers
again like I I think this is one of
those cases where they're just sort of
starting small and modest particularly
because it's so late in wildlands
lifecycle and if people embrace this I
mean they said that they are open to
ideas I think so many people have said
pubsey to them yeah I saw some people in
the YouTube chat also just wanting like
more players and
kind of just like free-for-all like
battle royale style what's up move in
thanks for stopping by securing it okay
so here's where our progression tree is
it's outside of the match okay that
makes more sense okay so now you can get
that scout you want okay so this is my
favorite guy he's on our tail he has
artillery on his drone so he can move
snipers like anytime they're just
camping somewhere they get a good
warning before it comes in so it's fair
and then you can buy the perks okay so
quick hands is reduces revive time
that's pretty awesome do I have enough
for that too
yes I need your coins total so nice okay
let's do that and then I don't know if
you can buy weapons let's get one more
class going over your last upgrade point
at least for now I mean your unlock
you're basically getting a point per
level so there's the enforcer to that
you have mentioned so he's I don't
really like the LMGs yet that's fine but
the enforcers the guy who can pull the
spot off of his team and onto himself
which is actually kind of cool they do
suppression let's just go a salt for now
thanks Braden Williams he says the
download is a 23 gigabyte download not
exactly sure which platform out thanks
for that information
I think there's as much as 30 on PC okay
it's big because because you don't have
to own the base game I'm assuming they
have to download a lot of the base game
all right here we go now for those of
you tuning in if you didn't know we were
playing Ghost Recon wildlands but the
ghost war beta or Ghost Recon war beta
and that is open beta as you can see at
the bottom of the screen so if you want
to play that go get it so on its own
though not through the game I'm curious
how people felt about wildlands it's
interesting I feel like like it was on
the top of the charts in the UK for a
long time it's a really casual Ghost
Recon game like I think a lot of people
like tactical Ghost Recon games and
honestly wildlands was very much as the
gaming
hung out with your friends and just sort
of [ __ ] around there wasn't a lot of
tactical elements to it retro let's go
to be self-service Braden woman says
it's 23 gigs on the PlayStation thanks
for that Raiden someone was saying that
it was like going through maintenance
for them because now hopefully that's
not the case maybe you shouldn't have
backed out up there you go
just wait it out guys so here we go
I think right I will say we have a lot
of like NAT type issues in this office
we're good though now I'm pretty sure
this little kid will find out yeah but
sometimes you play doesn't like our
doesn't like our corporate Internet but
it's we found some ways around it kind
of VM robbers is not a fan of for V for
PvP I think it's fine coming from a
playing destiny to a lot and still
playing they switched all their PvP mode
support before instead of like 66 and I
think it's fine I don't know it doesn't
bother me necessarily I will say that
going from 66 to 4 before it does expose
certain players more whereas maybe in
the past when you had 6 people it was
easier to tell it wasn't as easy to tell
like if someone wasn't as good at PvP
whereas with 4 before it's kind of like
if you have some guy that's not that
good it could really bring down your
team yeah I mean what they're
experimenting right as you said so on
the reverse side of that the thing that
concerns me about 4 v 4 instead of 6 v 6
and destiny is one really really good
player can wipe the other team in in 4 V
4 it's 66 you have like another 2 people
to help take them down you can team fire
them or something like that yeah techno
guy 3000 YouTube chat saying I've been
waiting for this since launch let's see
how it is because I love Ghost Recon
think Aaron's enjoying it for the most
part but it's only been you know what 30
minutes yeah I mean what I like about
this game is the slower pacing I don't
like how fast shooters have gotten with
some exceptions
I still love titanfall titanfall very
intentionally though keeps you alive
longer through their mechanics so even
though it's fast
you tend to stay alive for a good period
of time yeah I've always loved these
types of multiplayer shooters that are a
bit slower again like huge fan of Ghost
Recon phantoms in future Soldier so I'm
glad that we have something although
this feels very much like a first poked
at it and wildlands is such a good
sandbox has such a big sandbox with so
many vehicles that I just can't see them
if this succeeds I can't see them not
wanting to expand out into that sandbox
more I mean for tonight just did battle
royale before and I can do it
wildlands can do it yeah but they're
starting here this is what you can play
open beta as mentioned for those of you
struggling to get into matches or things
like that or can't find it it's not
actually in the Ghost Recon wildlands
game it's it's just kind of like a
standalone thing that you have to
download right now to play it if it is
open beta also I don't know if this is I
think this is free right is it gonna be
free when um they eventually come out
with the mode or so it's a free open
beta right now but it's the DLC is DLC
so it's got to be part of the season
pass gotcha oh it could be the stream if
you're thinking that it looks choppy
maybe I I don't think it's like that
much better I mean like visually if I
look better on PC but it's not gonna be
like a huge difference but there is some
weird choppiness I've seen when people
die like after the fact but other than
that I haven't it's been pretty solid
for me I don't know if maybe it's just
your
under rule you like as mentioned you
have to download this as a separate
thing you got to look up Ghost Recon or
ghost or beta once you download back 23
gigs for ps4 you can then engage and
play this as its own separate thing
oh that's where the loadout is - sorry
it's in the appearance screen we'll take
a look at that after this round Braden
William saying I agree about the speed
of first-person shooters now maybe
because I'm getting old
he puts 41 there I find I like the
slower pace tactical shooters I wish I
had a PC to play player unknown
yeah well Braden one cool thing coming
in the future is if you have an Xbox one
you can play player unknown that way if
you don't have a PC so maybe hopefully
you have that good mention ps4 just now
so it could be a little bit for that but
uh that's another way to play pup G but
we are currently just playing on a
normal ps4 not a ps4 bro also I'm pretty
excited about the idea of cross play oh
they're already there so like fort was
it fortnight accidentally did it this
week yeah I was like a weird bug or
glitch thing that they patched in or
something
they just straight-up accidentally did
cross play which are they didn't start
charging us where are you know there's
an enemy drone there do you know how
long the beta spore was there a date
window a couple of days I can I could
look at other yeah I can leave that up
for you
huh interesting I did not find them but
I think we're fighting in the woods well
as my team break it up don't break up
team this is not a game where you want
to do that this is a game where you want
to stick together and be friends it is
now available through September 26
it's our so it the open war beta dates
are 921 to 9 25 so you have about a four
day window to get in and play it but
yeah open beta so here interested it
goes until the 25th and it started today
so that Scouts started from the woods
I'm gonna guess they're out in the woods
right now I'm gonna try and put the
tower I want to try and rope-a-dope this
guy um so I was doing this in the beta
and enjoying it oh those are your
commands so I have a mine that I can put
down and if they spot me they might go
from my mind
they might rain like me your guy just
knife to somebody which is always good
the way that you stick the walls is a
little bit weird what's up guy who are
you running from
I find a Friendly Fires on don't step on
my mind okay oh that's actually is there
something that indicates for you as a
teammate there's a mine nearby or are
they just kind of screwed if they just
run near it that's a mortar drone it's
telling me okay on the roof he's
throwing later lightning angle man bro
oh there he is bye see you later
oh okay so they see him and I've got a
I've got a
see also dropping artillery is that what
he's doing yeah so I guess they don't
really limit okay
let's even get this guy you don't really
enjoy MIT once you stop and take cover
this is where my team says don't wait
now he's like glitchy running so the
best thing that I can do right now for
my team is just steep him marks
so like airman derping Tim there's gonna
see him coming towards him because I
have it marked or toss grenades at him
is that my guy that is my guy all right
are we taking any of them down where are
we at here we go I think they're all in
the woods
accessing data get my ships okay I don't
have many 44 brings up a good point
though he says so begins the trend of
releasing multiplayer months later
program pinch
yeah yes so there's there's like a
mental game there like our guy went for
the tower we knew that that would pull
them in to try and kill him and we were
ready for the ambush so I like it like
there's it's team deathmatch but there
are things you can do to poke and prod
at the other team I believe you did say
this was part of like paid its double
check that could be part of the season
pass I will double check that then my
best guess is that as part of the season
pass because it is DLC I'll take a look
man of many 44 what's up ash you a Shia
Ashish dude I think that's all wildlands
what's included hold on see if the free
PvP thing here is just not the beta
though all players though will be
handled ate or handed a free PvP update
after release so it looks like the PvP
is actually free no awesome assuming
this is correct what do you know someone
else can o verify or clarify if I'm
incorrect what it looks like the PvP
mode is free yeah I have a GameSpot
article here it says wild lands DLC
detailed free PvP mode coming after
launch and that was in March so unless
things have changed it is free okay
everyone saying PvP is free thank you
cool alright thank you we'll go with
free I like free yes free good free
makes the people happy yeah so that's
cool
glad that that is a thing for the
players that did buy Ghost Recon
wildlands and want to enjoy a PvP mode
hopefully evolves maybe people get lucky
and maybe it'll get kind of like that
pub G experience I don't know if they're
gonna make that this is the currently
the only mode that you can play which is
44 ok yeah a lot of a lot of comments
that it is coming as a free update cool
I'm glad because actually I think it
definitely expands out an already very
expansive game and again like there's
there's no other Ghost Recon style games
like this out right now that have PvP
yeah hello and nonnamous hacker how are
you and Kyle wait Nick says can I please
have your job although I will say but
thanks for tuning in and helping me keep
my job I guess I mean also if you want
to become a youtuber sky's the limit
Jimmy I would just say wait because we
were joining a match and it took us a
few minutes just to finally get there so
just be patient don't keep backing out
of matchmaking I would say leave it
there just give it a second it will get
there I think the more and more people
are slowly downloading the beta so
you'll have more and more people to to
get matched with but for now just try to
be patient Wow Airmen derping Tain's oh
no super aggressive right flank
yeah let's see how this goes see what
happens when you just run for it I think
it'll work especially if like people are
trying to like grown-up and stuff like
that
he's also must be a classic and run more
than me because like a Scouter I'm on
the other class that you kind of had a
run juice right now what's that Victor
land how are you doing so they're
drowning that means they're around here
somewhere yes frosty saying in beta you
have access to six out of the 12 classes
in eight out of the 12 maps that's good
knowledge to do start his training all
right recruit what's up Nicholas at card
Dennis de cárdenas a good chance if they
are all currently right next to me where
are they I'm getting those away the
lumber mill that building okay four five
I think is in there and that builds in
there yeah he's definitely in there
oh well pincer maneuver oh man
everybody's hanging derping tonie's
flying on the screen here a little bit
it is beta he's not cheating no I don't
think
smoked them here and there's two of them
in there frag out
derping Tangier homes knife um do you
endure be didn't do it dude herb you got
him right yeah you got Wow
he glitching I have no idea he looks
like he's kind of warping around that
could just be lag I'm gonna go with lag
or because it's a beta or he found some
sweet like Bert say something I don't
know is eet bagging though easy tea
bagging okay well we took a lot of me
down there that worked out well connect
climb and just gotta camp some bodies
other bodies yeah how many did we take
down in here three because boy I would
just say keep trying to do what you're
doing
take it as a hobby person cause if
you're trying to be a youtuber and just
try to keep kind of maybe the content
that you like making the content that's
up here so yeah I mean passions what's
going to take your audience with you
yeah John Martinez is not enjoying
watching our gameplay you don't have to
be here but you don't want to watch it
don't get up knifing Jenna nice that's
good teamwork there suppress them get
eyes on you your guy fling some boom
easy-peasy
players seem really spongy yeah they
seem to have a good amount of health
which is you know pretty like it's a
change of pace I think that it's cool to
see kind of longer kill like longer to
kill I'm also to be fair like I'm not as
good and thumbsticks as PC so I'm not
really landing the headshots I guess the
real question is on PC with people who
are landing those headshots how fast
they go down that is true I'm mostly
hitting people in the like torso lower
torso yeah really suppressing them there
is a class for that there's a class that
just suppresses I could try it
all right they're not very good at
hitting things they're just get it
showing everybody on the map where they
are so you need people next to you
helping you out in that case because you
are messing up the other team's ability
to shoot you unless they're there's
certain classes that don't aren't as
impacted by it
B calves boy so you know obviously keep
as mentioned before you keep doing what
you're doing in terms of your YouTube
channel because ultimately that will
become a good or like real for you in
terms of like if you ever get the job
opportunity or opportunities to
interview for a job at like a GameSpot
or an IGN or you know like a kotaku or
polygon I think you just have to be I
think luck plays a lot of plays a lot
into it sometimes because you like you
have to be lucky if there's even the
opportunity and then if that ever comes
up just trying to showcase your
knowledge your wealth of knowledge in
gaming and you know the content that you
can create based off of this channel
that you already have so that's kind of
some advice I guess or the tips I guess
just keep doing what you're doing keep
looking out for those jobs maybe hope
that you have somebody on the inside
that can at least get you an interview
if that's possible again part of that
look so is there a shotgun in this
multiplayer have not run into a shotgun
yet I mean I have to say like YouTube is
a very competitive space these days even
competitive against
may assume game journalism so I mean
again just making videos is the best way
to to get into the business of making
videos I did this actually I feel like
so calm cuz a lot of people in chatter
kind of I was just I was just thinking
that when I fired up this morning that
this does feel a lot like SOCOM it has
that it has the pacing of SOCOM is what
I think time to kill hey dude watch out
he's like behind us in the barn
turning the barn there's already a man
in the barn how do I tell my team yeah I
think I saw Kevin takes him out all
right Kevin stands Irvington is doing
the whole run stab tactic man he just
got somebody his derping Tim like legit
and he's got it it's console it's harder
to like hack on console that's there's
something like weird glitch with a
certain class you know what I mean
she's lagging it out no I don't think so
okay I swear to God or one of their guys
went in this barn and I'm not smoking it
okay well we'll find out he's right
there he's right there
I was so low okay okay so once you get
the tire it'll give you some vision Oh
now some shots over there to the left
oh yeah Durrington might have finally
chirped his last derp nice Oh cuz he's
dead
okay hold at least one guy i I've you
that as a good trade um give me more
room checked out cars oh if you want to
play this it is on its own you have to
search for it in the store or on Steam
because it's not part of the base game
so currently the beta is on a separate
thing on its own separate download your
swag sir that's probably uh unlikely
know what I would do is definitely not
quit your job and start making YouTube
videos I would continue to make youtube
videos and work your job until you feel
like you have been successful enough on
YouTube to that not work continue doing
your current job
have you guys had a night match yet as
Brandon Rivera has asked I don't think
so there's been one that was like kind
of like late afternoon but it was like
at least we've had some rain but I don't
think we've we've gotten ate like purely
Dark Knight match in the preview event
which we were just playing this we did
see a night match so the weather is
random and you can get thermal vision I
don't know I can check right now to see
if I already have it okay yeah and
derping 10 is level 10 crazy
I got derp so hard I'm appreciative of
dirt being just running around I think
everybody yeah I think Jimmy I think it
tries to like fill out most of the
roster if you're in between rounds
before starting again cuz I did notice
that there was like a time where Aaron
was waiting a little bit longer than
usual in between rounds so that they
could fill out the team's I think so
right now the weather effect is it's
1,600 hours the his storm
so this is more of a range map so either
want to take appointment with me or I
want to take a sniper if I don't have
that actually so the the base level
recruit is the only other guy we saw who
has it designated marksman rifle which
is a good tip if you're on a long-range
map and you can't get your sniper
currently Nelson there's only deathmatch
I don't think they've spoken about like
other modes just people want other modes
yeah and I had a good conversation with
DES at the preview event and they said
they're taking a lot of feedback from
people everybody under the Sun has told
them they want battle royale or
something like battle royale and again
like it is a bit disappointing that
there's no vehicles like they could have
gone the GT a ride a little bit more
especially given how like rich enlarge
the wildlands world is so we'll see if
they can add in some modes later that
maybe pull either in pub G or GT a
direction slightly the nad Mel in
YouTube you do not have to have the main
game to play this it's an open beta so
you can just go download this on its own
and play it and try out see if you like
it that's PI the part part of the reason
probably is like hey if you do like this
mode maybe by the game if you have it
you know also see bro if for some reason
you can't download it maybe try turning
off your PlayStation and seeing if that
helps you like restart your console and
then try Riga downloading it that way
that sometimes helps
scout down
okay Scout down the only real advantage
to doing that or you don't have enough
story distance might have mentioned yeah
it was like 30 we've determined it's
about 30 gigs there's somewhere between
20 and 30 depending on the piece here I
really want to get in that tower up
there I don't know if I can make it
before I get nope I don't want to do
that there's a sniper right there I
haven't tried flashbang grenades yet you
think I can here's a question from
Brandon Rivera so everything that is in
question mark do you have the weapon in
the main game to use it in the PvP no
it's completely separate I can't go to
the two of these guys arrange let's get
over to my guy here and try and help out
are you still playing the same pot or
did you point man okay up derping
tonight yet another person chirping
Tina's just applause with that night
maybe he just knows the routes surviving
yeah there is oh man okay now there's a
hero okay John Martinez wants to know
why are you wearing flannel in the
desert that haven't managed to customize
out of flannel yet yeah
we're a lumberjack guy so I'm not in a
great position there's a guy up on the
hill although no cooperate coud raise
he's trying to get up there and get them
when if it'll work he's he's scouting
right now
I'll be shooting something Adam got him
all right the other two guys are over
here I do it you're gonna try to get
that recon so I don't have a drone as
his class Oh derping hands down yeah and
they revived oh man not not looking good
see how this goes dry you should try
flashbangs I don't know if they really
are helpful or not the Nano so censor
your answer but later on at the beta
codes I'm not sure about that cuz
currently the beta is like a separate
entity that's not tied to the main game
so I'm not sure that belt that made walk
around in front of me that's where it's
actually advantageous to be in
third-person over-the-shoulder David gal
it was a part of the game what is
currently not part of the game
Jonathan's asking why not use a
suppressor even I do not certain classes
only wolf and asking for a convoy gain
load with vehicles I would love that
I would love any kind of vehicle mode
where you have to kidnap or get
something to another place this feels
like such a sniper map and you can't
switch in between rounds it doesn't look
like right so you're kind of locked in
once you at least currently you're
locked I think you can pick o in between
yeah totally okay cool
see you doing that so I'm not good with
DMR's but you can go multi class let me
let me do my support guy cuz he at least
has artillery strike do we know if this
beta is on Xbox as well I believe so let
me double check I think it's all
platform let me just double check make
sure yeah it's also on looks like Xbox
one too
yeah also I guess to note that we didn't
note if you don't have Xbox gold or like
yeah I just live or whatever the gold
whatever they it is that you need to be
going on to the multiplayer like yes
plus you can't play this game so there's
that so I just checked I definitely
cannot put on a suppressor it must be
I'm I'm gonna throw this out there I
can't confirm this but I'm gonna assume
that it's gonna be a perk like one of
the classes can do it
Nelson leo commit oh we kind of talked
about why 4 V 4 vs. 66 maybe not why as
to much as so much to like just talking
about 4 before vs. 66 he's thinking that
it would be better 66 I think that with
all the revives that you can potentially
pull off I think 44 is fine and I don't
know if these maps are big enough for 66
but hey who knows it's its beta they're
just starting so who knows if they
decide to make it 5 e 5 or 6 p 6 it
could it could just be something they're
feeling out or trying oh this guy right
trying to creep up like derping t'n even
in my works all grenade oh wait oh you
put a mine there okay I was like what
are you doing
I like noise are there I didn't even
think about that can they disarm your
mind at all
oh there's guy behind us or do they have
to like shoot it I think there's a dude
behind us and I gotta be careful oh he
just got sniped derby dude oh you killed
Irvington
yeah but he's up on that hill no you
killed Irvington with your grenade
tonight
oh he knows that sniper still there okay
who's gonna revive right now
nope unmarked I don't like this yeah but
there was a dude over here did you kill
I know he was like a top was covering
during dinner right that mine strat
worked though just mining the body yeah
but then it kind of did it because he
didn't die right away from the revive
right like it showed it after it's
almost like you did damage with your
mind I better market hey let me mark
where am i if there's a dude just dude
right here right here he's right here
don't do it don't get on me he's right
here he's right here
let's go watch him die there's how's a
good one
I knew he was covering that body I
should I told you to go do that that's
my fault
I love the mind see bro you gotta look
for like ghost recon war beta not Ghost
Recon wildlands beta it has a different
girls are different
yeah it's called ghost war or like as
nutsy says it says or has like mode in
the name or something like that
friendly fire with grenades are on yes
and and mines but not actual friendly
fire with gunfire in the regular mode so
there's a custom match you can make from
the main menu oh that you can turn it on
you can i'll check i think you can turn
it on from there cool but your needs
it's definitely on gotcha so if you guys
for those just tuning in or maybe just
coming in we were playing the ghost war
beta which is pvp mode for Ghost Recon
wildlands it's an open beta on PC ps4
and Xbox one and it runs until the 25th
of September so you got a couple days to
try it out it is a standalone thing that
you download from the store so it's not
in the actual game but if you have as
long as you have like PS Plus and gold
you should be able to find it download
it and play it active for four days
comment would've been cooler of PvP was
integrated in the open world so I'm
gonna call it a game that people might
laugh at but defiance the game did that
really well
they had like a conquest mode in
defiance that was large-scale it used
vehicles and there were actually enemies
on the capture point so you were not
only fighting each other but you were
fighting in this case you'd be fighting
the cartels uh-huh
and also like I talked to Ryan Schubert
about this a lot he really likes how
gangs work in some of the earlier GTA's
where like maybe sectors like certain
when you're fighting certain gangs are
hostile to your team as the other team
yeah like I think there's a there's a
lot of potential here for that PvP in
the PvE as it is there are deer and
llamas we got startled one time yeah
that was that was kind of cool though I
like that I thought it was a person and
then we're like oh no [ __ ] it's actually
just a deer like okay yeah don't shoot
that guy don't don't give off
your position right it's funny because
the deer also show up on thermal vision
which is kind of funny in the comment I
already captured El sueño I'm sure that
when you capture a drug lord there was
just another drug lord to take their
place yeah that's how they rise up right
it's like narcos for anyone that watches
narcos even if you get rid of one
there's gonna be more than one I mean I
know that wildlands was just supposed to
be stupid fun I did think it was a
little tone deaf to the fact that like
oh yeah cool you just killed drug lords
and that solves all your problems like
we haven't tried that a lot of times I
kind of wish the game had been a little
bit self-aware of that because if you
kill drug lords there's just more drug
lords alright let's do this I'm gonna
stick with the class that I'm good at
sure have you are you able to show some
of the perks and stuff yeah I think
there's a perks right there right we
have to back out to the main menu to
actually do the unlock tree which is
wide I think your match is about to
start we can do it after this one and
just go through some of the menus and
stuff for people
yeah tell you what right after this
round we'll definitely do that well back
out we'll take a look at the menus yeah
and then we'll maybe call it after that
we'll see so you still have
customization there's a whole perk tree
that you can go through so you're gonna
run artillery right yeah I like sticking
to one class for a while in these games
just cuz you get good at them have you
guys had any problem finding games Louis
Smith I would say earlier just now like
right before we started getting into
these same matches here we were it took
a little bit to get into a full match
but like I mentioned to someone else as
well just kind of be patient and let the
match kind of fill up like even then
Aaron was kind of stuck there for a
little bit until the match filled up so
I would say just be patient another
thing that we noticed was there were mid
Matt joins which is good because you
don't want to get in a situation where
half your team drops out and then you're
just hosed and also I want to say that
there's probably not like
huge population right now I'm sure
people are finding out slowly that hey
this is available I can download it play
it so I'm sure once we get more players
that will become easier to get into more
anvil one gaming our own Ryan Schubert
asking are the weapons from the main
game wakey-wakey they are not based on
your unlock I just saw him go left from
over here that's asking everything on my
menu is locked why you have to play the
game level up and as you level up you'll
unlock you'll get unlock points which
will then let you unlock another class I
know there's like subclass I guess right
because there's like classes and then
there's like characters within the
classes so there's and this one there's
I believe six with two subclasses we
know one two three four there's four
with two sub boxes so there's four main
classes you can unlock in each one has
two subclasses said not available in
beta but you guys have everything I'm
not sure we'll check out the menus here
after in a second we're gonna get
through this match as mentioned you also
just start as the recruit the recruits
in the recruit has some base weapons and
he has an ak-47 which I'm not a big fan
of just because it's hard to control
Kevin Loretta and this like girl style
is for before it's team-based oh okay
way down up here derping tonight another
soul so there's he's heading for him is
that a person or a deer no that's theirs
frag out coming near to cool arrows
that guy's gonna try and cover his body
is on the tree logs right above you okay
I think there if we can just knock them
for you but yeah he was on those logs
there's buddy
alright so back up in action crazy I
can't move you can run mark yourself in
a bush
can you my cell marked I think you're
still bored hostels lost vegetable yep
i'll unmarked oh they're right here they
found to a key position
crazy got one for v1 yeah nutty you're
gonna have to play a bit as a recruit
and then you'll slowly get points to
unlock other stuff he should be right
here I think he was like right here
there are no respawns Kevin but there
are like pretty much unlimited revive so
I guess you could kind of say that part
of it's like artillery yeah argh I got
him
perfect in with a knife action Darington
like a boss so I like I don't know the
weird derpy games playing does I me a
little bit concerned and that's why
they're having a beta to be fair but
again like I go back to Rainbow six
siege where everybody the first couple
days my first couple weeks we're playing
super tactical with gadgets and then
they've realized that people who just
run into the room with Ross shooting
skills win every time and the game
devolved away from gadgets I don't want
that to happen to this game because so
is it still that way and see oh yeah big
time I mean especially since they've
gone the pro league direction it's it's
become a super fast game there's more
like counter-strike thing yeah it's
definitely pulled hard in the
counter-strike direction what's good
fella's says Mike bhana jr. we doing
pretty good we were trying out a new
beta for Ghost Recon wildlands called
Ghost or moon we turned off the mics
because of said f-bomb potential so but
yeah normally you would want the mics up
in case they are actually playing
tactically so mastered a hero I disagree
with that gadget statement oh you can
talk to Aaron about siege because I
don't really see no I'm curious what
gadgets what Ganges to find useful and
siege some random I'm not gonna say last
name how do you get the beta you just
have to download the ghost war beta as
long as you have PS Plus and
box cold it's a standalone thing right
now last for four days go check it out I
genuinely do like siege quite a lot it
just the game has gotten away from the
slower pacing that I originally really
enjoyed it's a matter of personal
preference though I think a lot of
people do like the faster pace of that
game X cry wolf asking a question that
all I think I have the answer for so if
you love a love tank does it just unlock
that class set or can I swap to the
enforcer or distraction later no from
what I can tell you have to unlock each
like particular person right so like
enforcer is an unlock right like we saw
that just now and I think you unlock the
artillery guy that is a specific pump up
even though you are a specific class is
that correct yes okay so yeah you'll get
more points though one per level it's
you play where was that guy who's
reading Dynamo 75 I don't know when this
will be officially out but as mentioned
by a lot of the chat and thank you to
the chat it will become a free mode in
Ghost Recon wildlands as long as you own
the game obviously when it eventually
does come out currently this is beta you
can try it it's open
so are you get am i dead I think you're
dead this is awkward because you're
still control art okay you know that was
weird because like it had the icon that
derping sin has right now and he's dead
right so yeah that's really whatever get
dirty Mordor at all or no I did it takes
a minute and it gives them like a
warning I do not have a gun that can
really reach up there that's fine you
got to do the flanks he's okay there's a
guy near the tree there maybe you can
flank them off
got his eyes locked down the other way
by your teammates or they throw me nuts
he saying once you start typing ghost
it's like the first one on the list
thank you for that that's appreciated Oh
God
Apple ID ID saying that go down nice
always just tell them to go down and
they die uh-huh I'm sorry nice to see
it's following the Heritage from Gras to
which is Ghost Recon oh I had that perk
they let me down quick hands
not like slow hands do you need the
headsets to be good to do good not
necessarily I mean it might help because
apparently footsteps are pretty audible
so if you have headsets on a headset on
a probably give you a slight advantage
always wear in front of me I like a
liquid gaming saying blood orchid has
moved away from Rush meta pitches he's
talking about Rimmer succeed moon saying
communication is key yeah I think if you
have a good squad that's talking to each
other and call it doing call-outs and
making sure that you know where the
enemies are obviously helps but a drone
system the marking system does help if
you don't have a like headset mic so
that you know he's right in front of you
he mine for us to carry over Steven
getting set on my mind
now there's two of them like this two of
them well don't keep moving huh hello
gamespot says VAR o I cannot see your
last name do you have some weird text in
there I can't read that but hello Vegard
are you doing bro
Mauro or bro more zero asking what do
you think so far I'm gonna let him
finish the round and then asking that
there's ghosts war doesn't have payload
as dream would succeed does no time to
kill pretty long prison it takes a bit
to kill someone as you saw just now I
don't know if you've caught up yet
though he's a good one he's right here
in front of me somewhere where are you
really tense Kenny one B 3 can Eren pull
off the one we three the only thing that
you can secure from what we can tell us
a recon tire which helps us give your
vision your team vision of the oh you
just popped the drum from right here
it's hard to win there's one VIII's
that's why my name is weird Vegard okay
Edwin vascular saying you don't need
headphones the game has sounding
indicators revealing loud bangs or shots
it does do a pretty good job from what
I've seen on the mini-map and whatnot it
does kind of have a yellow flicker pulse
to show where those people are shooting
from again I just feel like ultimately
headphones at the end of the day do
health if you want to go that extra like
the extra mile there because I don't
know for me I hear footsteps better with
headphones versus just like hearing it
from a TV but that's a my opinion oh so
what do you think of the mode so far now
that you've gotten a good like hour
under your belt and you kind of preview
I think you went to the preview event as
well yeah I mean again it's a personal
preference I like slower modes like I
would like more than team deathmatch out
of this game just because wildlands is
such a like a large rich environment and
I would love PvP in PvE like I'd love
car chases and some more GTA style stuff
so this is a good like start it's a good
baseline for what uh like a Ghost Recon
game PvP could be yeah I will say it
feels a little bit I don't know like
low-balled feels like they didn't really
push it as far as I would like them to
especially given all the vehicles in
this world but developers are listening
I mean from what they've what they told
me the preview events I think this is
their starting point and if this if this
succeeds and this is again this is the
way that they built Rainbow six siege
they start small they kind of promise
low and if people take to it then they
start adding a lot post-release and
again I've mentioned this early on the
stream but I think everybody has said to
them that they want battle royale
because wildlands is actually kind of a
perfect game for a battle royale style
mode so yeah like definitely get in the
beta and talk to the developers the beta
is free right now
yeah like so betas are a chance for you
to let developers know what's working
what's not working I think especially
because they're trying this so late in
the lifecycle they're all like right in
front of me
Gabriel currently the only objective in
this beta is team deathmatch so you're
just eliminating the other team as Aaron
mentioned this is kind of their starting
point
we'll see where they go from there but
that's just what it is currently Oh
wondering if the ghillie suit blocks
thermal like in the main that is a
really cool idea though yeah hmm what if
I just shoot my gun and bait them in
here I've got a good so I put a mine
down cruise down on my team let me check
really quick
wow that went right through the wall
cool that was actually kind of cool okay
he's coming through Apple ID saying
hopefully it will be popular and they'll
add more stuff like modes of Maps I'm
not abandoning it like they did with
Future Soldier like a sleeping face and
Braden Williams funny amen
dammit you know kind of put myself in a
box here literally okay watch out cuz
they can actually you know don't do that
how many maps that means I'm the only
one in here yeah this is not gonna go
well well you have the mine oh yeah
second you kill him are you killing with
the mine okay you have another mind
wearing with this oh he's right there
but the old stall tactic that's cool
that you can get shot dude though yeah
oh now someone's telling me four to five
maps in beta I would listen to the chat
more than me as they have played a bit
more than me and know more but I can
always look it up for you let's find out
oh you guys lost you should go check out
again use and then we might wrap up
after that so they back out I think so
can you not if not that's fine you can
play another match that's fine
looks like you're fine totally fine it's
better that you have a skill point
anyways it's something I can back out
let's take a look at the we'll take a
look at the menu so people can see me
and Irvington was good with that knife I
don't know what that class was but he
was just running around with fast feet
and a knife yeah I mean it is day one
that's when you're gonna flank the most
people because everyone's trying I don't
know it's kind of tough like you said
like you think and play the game
tactically but then you might have that
one lone wolf that's just gonna run
around stabbing people and you don't
expect him to necessarily be next to you
to stab get that stab we going on so you
know yeah there's a couple times where
somebody was on us way faster than I
thought they should be which was
probably that class
okay so just flipping through the menu
here so you start multi class you have
the recruit so the recruit has a a que
and actually they have one of everything
they have an LMG an aka and a DMR I
think that the only other person who has
a designated marksman rifle for the
longer maps which is good to know okay
and then you get the Sprinter which you
could have could unlock if you want to
which is gonna give you a speed boost
there then you have the point man so his
guy is automatically mark enemy planted
devices within 20 meters so he can spot
my mines
that's the perk yep the tank is the not
often a the perk on him yet so diverting
this one so the tank is interesting is a
hundred and fifteen percent health and
when your team is spotted you can
actually pull the spot to him so he's
the only person who spotted and
everybody else in your team gets
unspotted that was the enforcer I
imagine he's a good you have to be
communicating really well so the same
for the enforcer it's this guy
this tank is enforcer excited okay
gotcha so and and I guess even the
appointment has plus 20% health so if
you just get in a 1v1 he's got a good
chance of taking you down as long as you
have good aim then you've got the sniper
who can pierce through walls all
we just saw somebody with an LMG do it
to us so apparently more than one class
can do it and they can increase revived
timer of a downed person so it increases
like the amount of time it takes to
revive that person so that seems
designed for them to camp a body like if
they shoot somebody they go down they
get more time to shoot the person who
comes in and revives them makes sense
Ranger is locked right now not available
in open beta yep
so here's the enforcer they have advance
suppression which is where your screen
gets all shaky when they shoot at you
yeah I still think the LMGs aren't that
great just because they don't kill
things is in front of you as good so you
have to be with somebody else who's you
can get shots on target and you are
literally just there to shake up the
other team so this is my favorite class
right now scout so quick hands lets you
revive people faster which is pretty
clutch yeah we saw you do that just now
and it was pretty fast compared to the
first time you've done it so and then
they yeah so they just interact and
revive much faster but they also have
the mortar strike which i think is
really good and then they have a drone
that is just way better at spotting
people and that's it for the beta yeah
cool yeah so just so you know there are
five Maps currently of the eight is what
I'm reading again just so you guys know
if you want to try this out it is
currently an open beta on xbox pc and
ps4 it is a kind of stand-alone thing on
its own so go look for the ghost war
like beta you download it
I think ps4 was twenty three gigs
someone was saying closer to thirty for
PC but it's available from the 21st to
the 25th starting today so go try that
out if you like Ghost Recon wildlands or
interested on how maybe this plays and
then as Erin mentioned you know provide
that feedback to the developers saying
like oh this is working this isn't
working I would like to see this I would
like to see that and hopefully as some
of the chat had mentioned maybe you guys
will get some of the stuff you guys oh
my camera doesn't work because somebody
turned it off there you go but hopefully
you guys get what you guys want or
maybe a battle royale mode it seems like
that's the one that most people are
clamouring about but we do appreciate
you guys tuning in Thank You Aaron for
playing I think it's pretty good little
taste of what we could get from that
game and of course we'll be back
tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. GameSpot live as
usual we're gonna be playing EKKO me and
Rob are gonna be checking that out Rob
really loves that game if you guys don't
know what EKKO is you're gonna find out
I think it's a it's a cool concept and
hopefully you guys tune in tomorrow if
not we'll see you next week but thanks
again and see you guys next time
thanks everyone later